Hi,
Dr. Peterson,
I'm a 17 year old girl and up tool gets turned to rare for someone like me who
listened to,
well,
maybe it is,
but I don't think it is.
So you know,
there's this idea that the only people who are listening to me or angry white
men,
he's a maker.
He might get in this whole idea
and brown women in the audience too.
As far as I'm concerned.
This is just so absurd as that.
I can't believe that this has even become controversial,
is talking to people about,
you know,
taking responsibility for the state of the world onto themselves,
the radical leftist identity politics.
City logs can only view this through the lens of their radical leftist identity
politics.
And instead of noticing that this isn't a political issue,
except that I don't like the radical leftists and the restrictions on free
speech [inaudible] for me,
it's the politics junkie.
It's found founders,
the politicians started to do the things that they don't get to do is staring
into philosophical realm or they stepped into the theological rep and they
should stay the hell out of both
the individual.
You're,
you're no longer where you should.
You've transformed yourself into a tire and not the good time,
not that there is a good conductor.
So now the consequences of God,
Carlos,
because our would be objected to that vociferously and with a fair degree of
success,
the only responsible can be mounted is the response that exists within that
domain of conceptualization of identity politics.
And so since I'm objecting to that,
then I must be the reprehensible editing slept well,
good luck with that story.
It's not going to work out because that is what's going on.
So and so to the 17 year old girl,
it's like who knows how many 17 year old girls are paying attention to what I'm
saying?
I need to,
I would say it's in the tens of thousands and perhaps hundreds of thousands.
And so the mere fact that that isn't the story,
that a small subsection of the ideological he committed partner media is telling
you by no means all of them by any stretch of the imagination doesn't mean it's
cannot be true.
So now when might be rare statistically speaking for 17 year olds to be
listening to me,
but her plenty of them that are,
I get letters from them all the time.
More power to them as far as I'm concerned.
It's a complicated message that lectures are very sophisticated and difficult.
It's great if,
if you happen to find that your interest is captured by them,
then there's something to that.
What advice would I give for teens?
Like you do what you think's right,
Kiddo.
[inaudible].